of the Republic of Albania his
Excellency edama the chancellor of the
Federal Republic of Germany his
Excellency Olaf Schulz and the president
of the European commission Her
Excellency urula Fontan at the end of
their statements we will continue with
the journalist questions I now give the
floor for the opening remarks to the
prime minister of the Republic of
Albania his Excellency
Adas it's
uh memorable day that
it's ending
against all predictions of Apple
weather
application and the desire
to host
as good as possible our special guests
has been stronger that all
meteorology expertise who told
us during a whole week
that this day would be a day of
rain and it wasn't so uh I'm uh grateful
to God and to the European
Union that made sure that uh this
day started with a beautiful
sun and it's ending with a nice
breeze as the summit it's
ending with uh
really fruitful
discussions really um open
exchanges and really truthful sense of
friendship I would never find all the
words needed to thank the
chancellor for having been
so graciously
open to the idea of bringing the summit
of the Berlin process outside the
European Union in
Tiana and uh I would never find the
needed words to thank the president of
the commission for giving to this Summit
something really
fundamental through the new growth plan
of the European Union for the Western
Balkans um this is a difficult moment in
time for
everyone and uh the challenges we are
facing all together are
huge because of the
subsequent crisis that have
hit both of us being uh Europe with the
you attached or being Europe with no you
attached and uh it doesn't seem SE that
uh things will get better before getting
worse in many
fronts including the
terrible um new
front uh in the conflict between uh
Israel and
Hamas but in the same time these
times have
forged our friendship have forged our
cooperation
have forged the sense of togetherness
and
uh thanks to the European Union
leadership uh what has happened has uh
been used to look forward with a much
stronger
confidence towards the Western Balkans I
don't want to be long because as you can
imagine I can keep you here till
tomorrow but these two German people on
my SES have schedule have time fixed and
have flight to take and have things to
do so um I don't want to take their time
here
because uh it's not every day that we
have the honor to host the chancellor of
the republic federal republic of Germany
and it's not every day that we have the
honor to host the president of the
commission so I'm sure that what they'll
say is much more important that what I
might say and of course then as always
uh I'm ready for the questions if there
is any
question addressed to me so
Chancellor uh please accept the
expression of my
gratitude for everything you are doing
for
us and uh for for being really a
impressive calm
Force insisting in
pushing the European Union and the
Western balans to get closer floor is
yours
for
in
here
but
partnersh
f
for
thank you Chancellor and now the
floor to the president of the European
commission Ursula ferland thank you
thank you very much thank you dear Eddie
for the wonderful hospitality and your
leadership at this Summit and thank you
Olaf for the excellent cooperation in
the preparation but also during this
summit we're here in Tiana working on
bringing the Western Balkans and the
European Union
closer but at the same time the eyes of
the world are now on Israel and
Palestine and our minds too there can be
no justification for Hamas heus at acts
of Terror for the brutal Slaughter of
1,400 people in
Israel in the face of this horror Israel
has the right to defend itself in line
with humanitarian and international law
and right now Palestinians in Gaza are
in need of humanitarian help and Aid
they cannot pay the price of Hamas
barbarism and this is why the commission
has announced to Triple humanitarian aid
for civilians in Gaza to 75 million EUR
and we are launching ing an EU
humanitarian air bridge to Gaza through
Egypt the first two flights will start
this week they will bring humanitarian
Goods together and we will keep working
with our partners in the region to
assess and address the needs on the
ground now turning to our work here
today last year I said that Albania at
the helm the Berlin process would be in
good hands and I was right so thank you
very much Eddie and Olaf for the very
good exchanges and for very successful
Summit but a lot remains to be done we
need to bring our economies even closer
and we need to speed up the reforms for
accession and this is why I presented to
leaders our growth
plan the new growth plan has the
potential if implemented to double this
size of the western Balkan economy still
in this
decade it has four pillars the first
pillar of the plan is bringing the
Western Balkans into the single Market
we basically open the door of the single
Market in seven key areas for the
Western Balkan companies already now
just to give you a few examples on
Customs Corporation e-commerce cashless
payments Road Transport electricity
roaming just to name a few now the
second
pillar is that the Western Balan
themselves have to complete their common
regional
market if they complete their reg common
regional market this could increase the
GDP of the western Balkans by
10% so the Western Balkans also need to
open to their own neighbors to the five
neighbors and part Partners they their
own
markets the third pillar is reforms if
we want to give access to the Western
Balkans to the European single Market of
course there needs to be a Level Playing
Field the same rules and standards this
means reforms are
necessary and these reforms also willing
bring the Western Balkans closer to
membership these reforms will also make
the Western Balkans even more attractive
for European investors
and make our respective economies which
is very important converge because today
we have a situation where the Western
Balan economies are at 35% of the EU
average so there needs to be lots of
work to be done to have more convergence
of the economies and finally the fourth
pillar of the plan is if reform e
efforts are being done they will be
matched by by increased EU funding for
investment in other words we have
proposed a 6 billion investment package
this is composed of 2 billion in Grants
and 4 billion in
loans and this same logic applies like
in our investment plan Next Generation
EU for the member states that is
investment and reforms funds will be
relieved upon delivery of reforms so it
is conditional it works very well in the
European Union I'm deeply convinced it
will work in the western Balkans too
thank you again this has been an
excellent Summit we want to move forward
and we want to move faster let's seize
the
moment thank you Madame President we are
now ready to take the journalist
questions
e in
English okay
is
[Music]
G an name um and a question uh to you uh
Madam president and prime minister um
did you also talk about the uh Refugee
Roots uh on the
Balkans uh today um um Madame President
what are your expectations to the Balan
countries on that issue and uh prime
minister uh what um uh what do you
expect from the EU and how do you
prepare for um more refugees uh uh
regarding the situation in the Middle
East
for
[Music]
is
Eddie would you like me to start with
migration
yeah I hope I have the phone mic that's
the mic work okay thank you very much
the the migration question uh you asked
me so indeed um there was a um limited
discussion on the topic it was not the
center of the discussion but of course
uh it was part of the discussion um and
indeed we are um have a look with the
European Union at the migration routs
migration routs for example coming
through the Western Balkans um I have to
say the first topic if we look at look
at it from the European Union's
perspective is that we get our internal
rules properly
addressed that is that we finish the
migration and Asylum pact these are the
internal rules within the European Union
but we are in a good way after having
agreed on the crisis
management the second part is the
operational part um where we can be very
practical and here we're working closely
with the Western Balkan countries for
example strengthening the borders uh by
delivering on frontex agreements not
with um each and everyone with but with
some of them or proper registration of
refugees very important is the alignment
in the Visa policy very important and
here our Asylum agency and the European
agency in general are also supporting as
best as possible so besides the legal
framework within the European Union we
already start to include the Western
Balan by operational day-to-day work um
to uh our management of migration at the
external
borders
yes we we had uh also
uh discussion about it and
uh I cannot add much to what uh the
president already
explained what can I say uh about uh
ourselves meaning Albania we are not
part of the Balkan route
so uh on that aspect uh we don't uh uh
influence
much for good or
bad uh this um
phenomenon but uh as always we are here
ready to
help we have done it uh all the way
through our history
Albania is the only country in Europe
that had more Jews after the second
world war than
before and uh a country that became a
sanctuary for the Jews basically during
the second world war and where no one
single Jew was
uh
released to the
Nazis then we had the experience of
the big
uh drama of the ethnic cleansing in
kosova we hosted here half
million refugees from kosova that were
obliged to leave their houses because
they were under a terrible terrible
pressure and
uh
literally uh hunted by milosovic regime
we offered uh shelter to several
thousands of Afghans after
the
uh um situation that was created by by
uh our alliance leaving
Afghanistan and we are ready to do so in
the future of course always uh
considering our modest uh modest
Dimension and our not uh Limitless
capacities
so this is uh what I can say to answer
your
question and um I fully agree with the
president that this phenomenon is
something that has to be
dealt uh in uh much more united united
Manner and uh by defining very clearly
the internal rules both for European
union and for us because the Western
Balkans are the most uh incred inredible
reality in the history of
geography and of uh mapping uh and I
don't think there is another reality in
the history of mapping where an entity
geographical and political
entity is surrounded completely by
another entity so practically we are not
in the European Union but we are
surrounded completely by the borders of
the European Union so somehow we are
part of
it uh all the time for good or
bad so weather was really nice but we
had problems with the technical system
of the
interpreting so it seems like Alexander
has made his choice towards Russia and
he's even today along Vladimir Putin
meeting in
China
so actually it seems like today Mr V
made a different choice but nonetheless
I would like to go back to the events of
the 24th of September how has the
European Union decided to take s
sanctions against Serbia because with
its Declaration of the morning Daya the
three terrorists it's as if they
accepted the authorship of what happened
in Kosovo so this is my first question
to all of you also to the chancellor and
to the president and I do have another
question for you president
directly
so actually my question is related to
your statements of today and the
statement of uh the council president
Char Michelle it seems like between you
two he is the most optimistic one and
you are the more objective one since he
declared actually a certain timeline for
the membership in 2030 for the
membership of the countries orz your
office actually after that statement
said that it is reforms the ones that
decide such um a membership or accession
so I would like to ask you what's this
what's the reason for this two different
standings between the you
two should be gracious with our guests
so let the other colleagues make
questions I'm here every day to be
grilled from you and uh very happily saw
so
but all right so I think the first
question also part of the question also
goes to me um what uh the horrible
attack of the 24th of September is
concerned we strongly condemn that um at
the moment being we are in a process
where the facts about the attacks need
to be established so we wait for the
outcome of the investigation and based
on that one we will decide on the next
steps of course in close cooperation
with our member states now uh the date
2030 accession is a merits based process
and there cannot be a rigid date where
regardless of how you reformed or not
you enter the European Union this will
be never acceptable for the member
states um or you have to wait till a
certain date 2030 would say would mean
next mandate no excession um so I think
uh the agreed methodology which we have
um in the European Council um is that it
is a merits based process and this is
much more rewarding for the countries
too because it's their efforts and their
successes that brings them forward and
it's a strong incentive also to do the
necessary steps for example if you take
now the growth plan the new growth plan
it is also merits based it says you
reform you do the steps forward there
will be funding and investment um and I
think this is a much better um incentive
as to have a very rigid process which
would then have an automatism this goes
against the methodology we have agreed
on so I have not to add too much to what
osula already said just shortly we
really condemn the attack against the
policemen and all the activities that we
saw in Kosovo attacking institutions
attacking people this is something we
will not accept and so it is absolutely
clear that the European Union and all
the member states also Germany are very
clear on that point we also ask for a
very intense investigation and ask all
to participate in this and support the
investigations that are done by the
Kosovo Authority which I think is
essential also that the Serbian
authorities are cooperating in this
field with Kosovo which I think is very
good if this would
happen let me add it is absolutely
necessary that we understand the
situation peaceful development uh in the
western Balkans has the needs the I
understanding of all states that uh this
will only work if they are not haunted
by the past but looking for the future
and if they try to solve the problems
they have with each other this is why we
work so hard to support Northern
Macedonia in its accession process to
European union and to get solve all the
problems first with Greece and later
with Bulgaria now there is a chance for
going into the right direction and we
really appreciate what the north
madonian government and the prime
minister is doing uh the same is uh with
discussing all the question s we see in
Bosnia heroa where there lot of reforms
are necessary and we support all those
truly working for a reform of the
government structures of this uh state
which I think would be very helpful and
this is the question we are working in
the field of Kosovo and Serbia I think
there are a lot of agreements already
reached and uh there was uh in the last
um time also an agreement which is on
the on basic criteria for cooperation
which is very much following an
experience we have had in Germany when
our country was divided but which help
to make life easier for people and for
businesses and all the things that are
practical for the life dayto day and I
think this is the same way we should uh
choose here and the Chance is now there
to get this and uh we continue to work
on this also on implementing all the
agreements that have been made in the
past and recently for instance also on
uh on the municipal Serbian
municipalities in the north of Kosovo
and their cooperation and questions like
this so let me assure you it is the
strict willingness of my government and
also the European Union it is the strict
willingness of for instance the French
the Italian and the United States
government to solve this conflict and
to pave the way for a good future of the
two states and both as members of of the
European
Union last
question okay Andreas Sinker from
Reuters um let me pass on the question
of the timing of enlargement to you
prime minister and
Chancellor um when um the EU council
president Michelle said 20130 is it too
early or too late for accessions um the
president
of the commission already answered this
question what's your opinion and second
question about Bosnia Bosnia hopes um
that um the EU makes a decision that
it's opening a session talks with Bosnia
like with Ukraine in December is Bosnia
ready for this step and this question
goes to you um president of the
commission as
well so possibly I will start the answer
of the question of the accession of uh
or the the opening of the procedures
with uh for Bosnia heroina will be given
first by the European commission so we
will hear from Ula they will tell us
their their survey and what they got
from looking at the concrete situation I
think in November so it will be that
time that we hear more about it and I'm
sure that the president will just give
you this advice wait for November but uh
we will hear the second is that
um I'm convinced that it is a mistake
that after TW after having met in
Thessaloniki 20 years ago we are not we
have not reached the accession of the
western Balan states to the European
Union so far it should have been done
already and this is why we are so
intensely working on making this
feasible and working for it and it will
happen as fast as it is possible due to
the questions that are on the table and
we all together have the same view the
president of the council the president
of the commission the member states it
is in the end Merit based but this is
not just a saying we work very hard to
make it happen that the states can do
the necessary steps that we can say it
is now the case that they can join and
my view is it should happen as fast as
possible and uh it could not take that a
long time again as it took in the past I
repeat to what I said in the beginning
if you give countries the idea they
could join the European Union and there
is a European dream in these countries
you have to work very hard that this is
happening and 20 years were too much now
we are in that situation but we have to
hurry up for getting a solution as soon
as possible
yes and um relatively short because it
is basically the same that I'm saying um
we have the procedure is the following
we are working at the moment being on
the so-called enlargement report which
comes every year um uh in Fall it will
be in the College of the commission on
the 8th of November and it um is The
View on all the countries that are in
the process um and gives a
recommendation to the European Council
the European Council will then discuss
the matter in the December yuku that is
the typical European Council for the
enlargement uh process um
indeed Russia's war against Ukraine
changed everything because uh it made
very clear that there cannot be for no
country that wants to join the European
Union and in between anymore between the
European Union and Russia you have to
decide um or you have to take choices um
on the other hand it also
accelerated um the process in so far as
we are working much harder and much more
intensively on driving forward the
necessary reforms and investment for the
accession process and I mean today was a
symbol for the strong will also of the
western Balan countries to join um and
therefore uh for me is important let's
do our homework and let's seize the
moment um this is a historic moment that
we really should use and let me conclude
uh by
underlining the very high importance of
this Summit because um I'm afraid that
then uh the followup will be what sh
Michelle said and what Ursula said and
this so Opera that is apparently the
same uh national sport from Germany to
Albania from uh North Macedonia to
Netherlands uh the point is that
something
fundamentally is fundamentally
changing so yes we can discuss about uh
how long it has taken we can discuss
about how tortuous uh this path is but
since uh the Russian aggress ression
something has fundamentally changed uh
we can see it because we are very very
attentive to every to every move to
every smile to every uh palpitation of
eyes when these guys speak and uh if
before we could we could see a part of
the member states very very you know U
uh po positive and uh some others uh
very skeptical today is not the same
it's a totally different Spirit number
one number
two uh this Summit has brought some uh
incredibly different um
results the new uh growth plan that the
president for n lion has uh extended uh
today also in front of you is not
business as usual is not more of the
same it's completely new
uh and it's completely new in the sense
that it's open it's it's it's showing
that the European Union is opening up
towards uh the non-member states of the
western Balkan by accepting to make
extra steps that
normally are related to the membership
so uh both
financially
uh and uh uh when it comes to the
openings on the single Market these are
huge things uh for the time being it's
not the it's not the full membership of
course but it's not the same that has
been before for every uh nonmember state
that had to go through all the homework
and that to suffer all all the pain of
uh having to be a good student and at
the end had to get back home with just
some good or bad results it's totally
different
and I I'm very very
um optimistic about this spirit and
about this uh approach because it means
means that there is a very high level of
awareness among the member
states and uh the this commission that
has been since day one um presented by
the president as a geopolitical
commission is uh changing things that
were inimaginable for us just few years
ago so how we would have get to this
point that uh with the backing of
Germany of France and of all the
countries the commission makes an extra
mile and says listen we need to support
you more and we are supporting you more
but of course you have to deliver
because it's with the European Union is
never you you never get a presence you
always get homework and then you get
also reward if you you deserve the
reward this is clear very clear and it's
clear even for member states you have to
be Germany to not be told what to do
otherwise otherwise you you have to be
told what to do so uh I strongly object
no but uh no I say it in I say it in uh
full heart and uh I love Germany by the
way so uh no doubt about that so no
problem uh with that but uh we know we
have learned it in the hard way I must
say but now we are fine you know we need
to push and push push and push and push
because as I always say European Union
provides countries something that you
can't find anywhere else something that
you can't
invent something that uh you can't learn
in the books which is the the amazing
knowhow of the of the state
building with uh Democratic standards of
institution building where you find it
who who can
uh teach you this except uh except the
European Union so uh uh I I can say that
uh this Summit has been
historical also in that regard because
it has opened a path that will be larger
next year and will be larger the year
after the next year and in the same time
we have to do our homework I I I've
never ever been in uh you know looking
for dates after I learned in the hard
way that getting a date with the
European Union is not just about how
much you love it's also about how much
time they have to accept a date uh now
it's not about dates it's about doing
your homework for yourself for your
country for your people for your future
and
then when uh the Stars will come
together we'll make the big wedding but
doesn't matter we can live in an well
articulated uh uh um how is called it uh
in Italian they say copia
defat uh a couple of facts not blessed
by the church or by the mayor but a
couple so we are going there slowly and
uh slowly but steadily and uh I really
thank again uh the chancellor for having
given us this great opportunity to show
uh how much we love the European Union
the president for having come today in
Tiana not just to repeat we are open we
our doors are open we want to hug you
and then no hug no she has come with uh
concrete with concrete proof that yes
some new space is opened it's for us to
make the best out of it
and to deliver and to behave it's all
about
behaving and uh I want to thank all of
you uh that have come from different
countries and uh have been so patient I
hope you didn't have a long boring day I
hope it was not uh the usual Summit of
the European Union because they are
tired of summit so they don't pay much
attention in details uh and I have
proposed basically to them to make
Albania The Hub of summits and uh we can
Excel and uh we can do we can do this
service better than everyone else but
it's to be seen because they have
consensus among 27 members thank you
very much again and uh I invite you all
for the last last step of this of this
journey of today with the big opening of
this pyramid who will be the largest
Innovation Center in the Western balans
thank you my
friend thank you thank you let's walk
down
here
sh